good morning John it's September 9th
2011 and you know what that means it
means that we are in the middle of being
bombarded by news stories about what the
world is like 10 years after September
11th 2001 and I didn't want to make my
whole video about that today but it's
kind of hard not to make at least some
of my video about 10 years after
September clothes so we're gonna start
out with that part 1 what is the world
like 10 years after September 11 I am 10
years older and I can't believe that
there are people watching this video
right now who are not alive when that
happened oh my god
second thing about the world after
September 11th no one is ever going to
win a war on terror war on terror is a
policy it is not a war you cannot win a
war against a noun you win wars against
armies and governments and other
countries you do not win them against
drugs or violence or terror
every time someone on any news show says
this is what we need to do to win the
war on terror you know what I want I
want to vomit onto their face something
I've learned since September 11th terror
not nearly as scary as it sounds and
that's probably why they call it terror
in the last 40 years in the entire world
this includes September 11th and all
other terrorist attacks more people have
been killed by lightning strikes than by
terrorists I am thousands of times more
likely to be killed by a drunk driver
than by terrorists so when I said no one
is ever going to win a war on terror I
don't mean that you'll never be safe
from terror I mean you're always going
to be safe from terror because you
always work moving on I have a poster
and you don't sorry about that you can't
have that one it's mine but we're
getting them back in stock hopefully by
Monday you can go to dftba calm and back
order them and they'll ship as soon as
we have them in the office part 3 I have
a friend who works for Blizzard
and he got me a Diablo 3 beta key so I'm
gonna start playing Diablo 3 starting
now on my gaming channel here is a small
snippet so I've got a barbarian here his
name is Kenneth and there's Mary I
shouldn't mention that this game is a
bloody and violent and scary musty
cellar that sounds like a place I have
to go
superior chest armor and I got magic
gloves and I got inferior pants
stomp eat it stump stumps have gold
shoes part for another amazing thing
that's happening to me right now is a
Frank's new website star dot me has a
mission of the day and today your
mission is to create music using sounds
that I made with my mouth you go and
there's a little good thing and you just
click on it and it makes noises and all
the noises are noises that I made with
my mouth I think we're on part 5 another
thing that happened on September 11th
2001 that maybe Giants released their
album mink car and recently somebody got
in touch with me and told me that they
were putting together a tribute album
that was just one dirty musicians
covering all of make car and I covered
banks from mink carts the first track on
the album huh that makes me nervous many
of my favorite note musicians are on the
album Tom Milsom Molly Lewis MC
Frontalot Driftless Pony Club Michael
Lombardo me and you can get a physical
CD now at mink car cover kamar you can
get it on iTunes or Bain campus where
all proceeds go to the FDNY Foundation
and lastly thing number 7 or 8 or 4 I
have no idea are so many great
nerdfighters on tumblr and tumblr is
kind of amazing to me because it's just
this place that encourages creation and
a really new and interesting and fun and
fascinating way and also follow fer
nerdfighters on tumblr because they find
the best things in nerdfighteria the
ever amazing work of shark i jones
including this laser eyed pizza John
fights Pizza monster I don't know it's
cool I don't know why and it constantly
reminds me that anytime anyone does
anything with the letters dftba no
matter how impermanent there's a chance
that another nerdfighter will see it and
it will make their day there sure is a
lot going on I'm gonna go to the
Internet and enjoy it I hope that you
all do too John I'll see you on Monday